before this video begins origin pc has
an exciting announcement
that's right they announced their brand
new thin
laptops ooh so thin they're thin
they're light but they're also equipped
with real time ray tracing technology if
you don't know what that means
don't worry i didn't either it basically
makes the game look very epic
the lights look good in the game it
looks actually pretty impressive i'm not
gonna lie
so check out their evo 16s it has a new
narrow bezel
design which makes a 16.1 inch display
possible
on a 15-inch laptop body that's pretty
cool featuring up to rtx
2080 with max q graphics card inside
damn boy it's not thick
it's thin that's right this laptop is
thin baby but still has that thick power
you want a larger screen don't worry
origin pc got you
the thin and light evo 17s offers a
17.3 inches of screen space damn boy
damn that's big screen and it also has
the same real-time ray tracing gpu
now if you want even more performance to
watch memes
their eon 17x is their desktop
replacement laptop
and can now be customized with ray
tracing
as well you want this you know you do
with an up to desktop class
rtx 2080 graphics card and an intel core
i9 9th generation desktop processor
damn boy check out origin pc link is in
the description
you can also learn more about rtx
graphics on origin pc laptop's website
smash like let's go on with the video
welcome everyone
leave your entries in the subreddit
and i'll watch submissions in the next
episode of fly
that's right youtube's favorite show now
sponsored by
youtube thank you susan very epic of you
january it's always great to have
sponsors this video is sponsored by the
way
hope you guys are having a great month
i'm having a it's a great month i'm
having a great time
okay i get more viewers than ever but
the subreddit now is at 920
000 subscribers wow almost at a million
can we become the greatest subreddit of
all time
pewdiepie submission what a great name
i'm really glad i'm i picked that name
very proud of that one it's on it's cool
the room is at a million
all right first meme i just
hate when i see people judge me of an
insanely biased article
or even a made up one discouraged face
first time i know how you feel ninja
it's okay
it's only happened to me every time it's
okay i
get it pewdiepie when you gain 10
million subscribers
so fast that your merch celebrating 70
million
gets outdated in a month pewdiepie
suffering from success if you guys could
stop subscribing so quickly
that would be great because um the
campaign hasn't even ended yet that's
great that's great can we hit 80 million
subscribers
before nine days listen okay they're
like pokemons these merch okay if you're
not
owning them all don't come complaining
to me afterwards
oh i didn't get the 70 millimeter 80
million
club coming soon everyone i mean it
looks pretty slick anyway
that's how mafia really works level one
crook level hundred mafia pass
i'mma make you pump like that
copyrighted music remember when you
could add music into videos
anyway the entire fan base when they see
pewds
with the cat ears on again guys
i know you're all worried for me i know
the content is getting a little bit more
edgy
there's nothing to worry about these are
different colors
see it's fine look david they even blend
into the tv how epic is that
huh that's pretty cool nothing to fear
my friends
me meeting pewds back in 2015 at his
book signing i was 11.
oh i think i remember him actually he
like cut the line or something
i was uh the best part of the experience
was that my mom
best friend worked for the crow and i
got special access
there you go i do remember you you
spoiled little brat i'm just kidding
thank you for coming and supporting my
book
it's a very nice book i still get
royalties so if you guys want to buy it
i mean i'm not complaining
please appreciate the fact that
pewdiepie dressed more formally
for the meme awards than their new
year's party
hey man it's all about priorities what
can i say
i actually wore the shirt but they never
no one else wore a short shirt so i'm
like
it's kind of cold anyway that's right i
got bullet into it i don't
only get bullied online people i also
get bullied
offline what can i say bowser
bowsette bread bread
i mean it's kind of scary how similar
they look i want them to collab or
something
oh my god i have eaten toblerone for
over 20 years and i just noticed there's
a hidden
animal in the mountain oh my god jesus
christ
has it been there all along how could we
have been so blind
when you post subscribe to pewdiepie on
our pewdiepie submissions
subscribe to pewdiepie when you tell
that's like if i say subscribe to
pewdiepie isn't it does it make a
difference
please subscribe using any other meme
format
using this new brad format so that he
can achieve his dream
no get out of here brad no one cares
about you getting jaiden animation
to host meme review getting jaden to
animate me for review
yes cause that takes no effort at all
okay jaden i'll appreciate if you can
get it done by tomorrow thank you if i
reach
80 million subscribers i'm br no i did
not say that
there's no way i said that i can't tell
at this point
what have i said god damn it well i
guess it's time for the legend to return
petition to add a timer on the tv so we
can see how much bride one and bride two
have to cut from the actual video
you guys want to know everything don't
you jesus christ
admitting you did something wrong other
youtubers did it too
i really appreciate ricegum's apology
video because it literally did
everything i would parody about
an apology video just deflect to other
people and not take any personal
responsibility 10 out of 10 apology
ricegum i really appreciate it
what the [ __ ] is that
is that supposed to be me why does that
look
like a virgin version of me who is that
person
why are there so many goddamn
look-alikes please host meme review
actually wish it's happening wait what
there's so many fake memes out there i
can't tell anymore
well i guess it's set in stone elon musk
hosting meme review
finally hit me up in the dms let's make
this happen
very epic i am so proud of this
community
hey look at that [ __ ] lasagna finally
now i can officially say i didn't peek
five years ago
thank you that's awesome very proud
pewdiepie calls me out
for mystery unboxing what is he talking
about pewdiepie legit said nothing
i just saw a papa gloria the ultimate
fusion newscaster
guys writescom gave away amazon gift
cards okay
i don't know how you can stay mad at
that did you not see the part where he
so generously gave away amazon gift
cards you know
nothing says taking responsibility after
you get to then just give away like a
couple dollars
here you go now we're even pewdiepie one
thousand five hundred dollars pc
watching me yeah you have a problem with
that level one crook
level 399 mafia boss damn
guys for only 3.99 you can be a mafia
boss as well
you can be just as epic guys i think
pewdiepie is a fan of punios now i'm not
supposed to have my own opinion
but yes yes i am a fan what can i say i
buy all the merch
pewds doesn't pay brad brad still spewed
speakers
puge oh my god
what a sh me man jesus christ
i found pewdiepie chair on the beach it
does this and it's authentic italian
plastic oh yeah well this is have
italian design and leather
i don't think so only zero damn
that's impressive guys i'm not
subscribed to pewdiepie yet because i'm
waiting for t-series to get close
to his subscriber count so i can be in
emergency subscribers
when he really needs it wow thank you so
much
i'm glad we have at least some people
that think ahead what are you some
normie subscriber that just subscribes
shake my hand yeah here it is
what is this first the market now this
along
you can't hide from the nine-year-olds
felix imagine just taking a pic of your
girlfriend and santa and seeing that
pierce is walking in the back
imagine having a girlfriend i don't like
this stop
when you're the best meme of 2018 but
you don't even get a feature in the meme
awards
excuse me okay that was good
if pewds killed hitler and hitler killed
himself
next meme petitioned to make the tv
screen green so we can
meme it on the subreddit okay that
should be easy
perfect poor brand
has to work two jobs
all these games look-alikes god damn it
nine-year-olds during meme awards meme
review meme review
option six well it turns out me remember
if you want anyway so stop thinking
you're cool and edgy for picking option
six
option six will never be anything ears
of evil
ears of purity that's right these are
the christian ears
that's why you can't see them they're
too holy christian channel
thank you level one crook five thousand
dollar milk
oh wow is this the one where he grows
bigger i'mma make you pump like that
[Music]
level 35 boss damn
jesus christ oh god stop god stop please
god stop just stop
there's no more no more no more obamas
please tsunami t is silent honest
the h is silent island the s is silent
q the u is silent pewds raised 246
000 for kids in india the media is
silent
it's like that bird box meme i've been
living in japan
and you know how everyone has been
talking about the photo every article
uses for pewds
yeah well this is the one japan chose
wow thank you japan arigatou gozaimasu
a very good thank you this is great i
actually don't want to get recognized in
japan so
if if japan uses this photo that would
actually help me out
part of the reason i like japan is the
light is because i never get recognized
please don't ruin japan for me please
this guy made a
pewdiepie themed ring with an nfc
chip so it subscribes you to pewdiepie
when you touch it
to your phones what you mean i can bro
fish people phones
and it actually subscribes to pewdiepie
that is epic
patricka dare designs found my
engagement ring
if pewds has no legs and vox bullies him
then that means box full is disabled
people
well i clearly can't read so i would say
that's fairly accurate thank you
that's how mafia works wait so someone
stole
a post and it got 26 000 upwards
that's how mafia works in case you
weren't sure
that is how mafia works what swedish
youtuber
pewdiepie has gained millions of
subscribers by uploading
frequent commentary about what
cooking oh my god please did she
actually answer that
did she answer cooking
oh it's this show youtubers
you've gained millions of subscribers
there's no audio uploading
frequent commentary about what
[Music]
again andrew
thinking pies and cooking
[Music]
oh i see you're a dumbass
correct answer is
[Music]
look at that nine-year-old in there look
at that nine-year-old right there he was
like i knew that
i knew that [ __ ] look at that guy he's
like i [ __ ] knew that
glass bye
hey now you're all
before i end this video there's one
thing i need to do
which is something that i never thought
i would do that's right
2019 who knows what's going to happen
next
because ah i'm a maverick now
that's right and i'm not afraid to say
it anymore
i am a freaking maverick and there's
nothing you can do about it
now logan asked me to wear oh actually
he didn't ask he demanded
that i would wear this shirt and yes
technically i didn't have to do it i
never agreed to do anything
but at the same time he i did ask for
help
he did reach out he took it he took it
and i i appreciate it you know
i think it's safe to say that i didn't
like logan paul before it was cool
but i think it goes to a point where he
just becomes a dead meme
and i was starting to feel bad for him
and you can tell he
is genuinely changing and we all make
mistakes
listen i'm not trying to make his
apology video for you all i'm saying is
that from someone that's personally made
a line mistakes
that will definitely haunt me for the
rest of my life i think
the kid deserves a break i do genuinely
hope that with me
showing my epic support it doesn't let
me down
and i hope that how do i it's so hard to
be nice why is it so [ __ ] hard you
know i'm seeing patterns to show that
logan paul actually is bettering himself
and uh
you know i want to encourage that i hope
i'm not let down at least
either way it doesn't matter here it
goes everyone
that's why i'm a maverick everyone this
is so
weird now excuse me i'm gonna jump into
a burning lava pit
and that's it for me for now see you
guys next time
okay so at the end of this i wanted to
give a shout out to the last two winners
of the pewdiepie tuber simulator
competitions so you guys can see that
the game is not dead
we had north pole and the winner of this
theme
was best pro noob so creative
so cool second place went to
ladyfantasma249
is that sponsor eagle really dope
submissions
and then the next submission the
competition was it's real
and the winner was commanding officer
i'm legit impressed by you guys
i feel like the fan base of this game
has just taken on its own which is
really dope
but i would love to see some more people
get into this
we have all kinds of submissions between
2018 like contagion
by x ruby gamer one this one it's really
fun to see
download the game in the description and
uh yeah let's do some cool stuff